- Ohh, there go my guys.
Huh?
Hey, yeah.
Ha.
Ha!
- What the hell
are you doing?
- What do you mean,
what am I doing?
I'm coming to step.
That's what I'm doing.
What are you doing?
- No, no, you got
the wrong step here,
brother, I promise you.
[stomping rhythmically]
- Joey, hey got a bunch
of Greek letters on him.
- It's your frat.
- That's our frat.
It's Ah Woo.
Brothers of Ah Woo
only know what we know
and go where we please.
Big brother, oh, Kev.
Oh, Kev, big brother.
- When were y'all founded?
- Day before yesterday.
- Day before yesterday?
Ah Woo was owned
by this Chinese dude.
He had a little Chinese store
on 13th and 5th.
So we licensed
the name Woo from him.
- A Chinese guy.
- Ha! Ha!
- He got a cane.
- Ha ha ha, now lick it off!
Hey!
- That's not the right cane.
This is for an old person.
- I don't know who it's for,
but I need the stability.
- Kev, look--just over there.
- For what?
- Look to your right.
- Unless they stepping,
I don't want none.
- They stepping.
- What are they doing?
- Stepping.
- This is like a banquet.
- They stepping.
It's classic.
- No, that's a bunch
of aunts and uncles
celebrating
somebody's birthday.
That's what that is.
Happy birthday!
- Decades. They've been
doing this for decades.
- Well, for decades it look like
they done got it wrong.
- I'm willing to bet the idiot
with the orange boots
got it wrong,
and it's only one person.
- So you calling
my chapter wrong?
This must be
the wrong address.
I'm gonna go outside and see
if it's next door.
- You better put a coat on.
It's cold out here.
- Brother, you don't get cold
when you step.
Hey, tell whoever aunt
in here's birthday,
I said happy birthday.
[hip-hop music]